[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días
un programa 100% dedicado al continente
africano con toda la actualidad de lo
que pasa en la cuna de la humanidad
durante la última semana mi nombre es
juan pupiales por liliana valencia
alemania ofreció disculpas por su papel
en la masacre de las tribus herero y
nama en namibia hace más de un siglo por
primera vez describió oficialmente la
masacre como un genocidio de acuerdo
financiar proyectos por más de 1000
millones de euros el gobierno de namibia
dice que este reconocimiento es un paso
en la dirección correcta durante su gira
por áfrica el presidente emmanuel macro
visito ruanda desde donde reconoció las
responsabilidades de francia el
genocidio de 1994 en ese país afirmó que
francia no fue cómplice pero permitió
durante demasiado tiempo que el silencio
prevaleciera sobre la verdad
la corte constitucional de malí valido
al líder golpista así me gusta como el
nuevo presidente interino de la
república en reemplazo del gobernante
destituido va anda según la corte el
coronel será el encargado de la
transición de gobierno
por primera vez alemania reconoció que
cometió un genocidio en namibia durante
su ocupación colonial a principios del
siglo 20 el ministro de asuntos
exteriores y comas hizo pública una
declaración en la que prometió designar
más de mil millones de euros a proyectos
de ayuda en la nación africana las
negociaciones sobre el camino de la
reconciliación es dura dos años y se
espera que más firme una declaración en
la capital de namibia en junio pese al
rechazo de la etnia heredero víctima de
la masacre
un esfuerzo por corregir errores
históricos alemán y anunció que había
llegado a un acuerdo con namibia
reconociendo oficialmente sus asesinatos
coloniales entre 1904 y 1908 como
genocidio de miles de personas de las
etnias herero y nama por parte del
ejército alemán özil estos mind big
nuestra meta es encontrar un camino
conjunto para una reconciliación en
memoria de las víctimas para ello
debemos reconocer claramente los asuntos
y momentos de la época colonial alemana
en la actual namibia especialmente los
cuales hechos entre los años 1904 y 1908
cannes clave hoy declaramos aquellos
hechos oficialmente como lo que fue un
genocidio
estas más con ello reconocemos también
nuestra responsabilidad histórica
stamets auctions by esta versión funk
foto alemania también dijo que
financiaría un programa de
reconstrucción y desarrollo valorado en
1.100 millones de euros para beneficiar
a las comunidades afectadas por las
atroces
se espera que la ayuda cubre a proyectos
de infraestructura atención sanitaria y
formación profesional durante 30 años el
imperio alemán fue la potencia colonial
en lo que entonces se llamaba el áfrica
sudoccidental alemana entre 1884 de 1915
los historiadores dicen que las tropas
alemanas mataron a 65.000 ereros y
10.000 nada más entre 1904 y 1908 los
supervivientes fueron expulsados al
desierto donde muchos murieron de sed o
acabaron en campos de concentración para
ser utilizados como mano de obra esclava
por el tour los alemanes hicieron pasar
penurias a mi abuela corrió sola creció
entre gente extranjera y la obligaron a
hablar una lengua extranjera
vivimos en la pobreza por lo que nos
hicieron en su momento ahora queremos
que nos devuelvan nuestra dignidad que
nos reparen y queremos que nos devuelvan
nuestra tierra aunque alemania ha
reconocido anteriormente su
responsabilidad moral por las matanzas
había evitado presentar una disculpa
oficial 2015 berlín inició negociaciones
formales con el gobierno de namibia para
un acuerdo que incluyera una
el presidente de francia emmanuel macrón
admitió desde ruanda la responsabilidad
del país galo en el genocidio de 1994
que dejó 800.000 muertos aunque el
mandatario no pronunció claramente una
disculpa el presidente en ruandés paul
kagamé aplaudió las palabras de su
homólogo francés mientras que desde la
principal asociación de supervivientes
lamentaron que no haya habido una
disculpa explícita veamos
más que palabras macrón llegó a ruanda
con el objetivo de normalizar unas
relaciones marcadas por el papel de
francia en el genocidio de los tutsis lo
más esperado una disculpa por parte de
un país que está acusado de hacerse el
de la vista gorda ante un gobierno que
de manera sistemática mató a 800.000
personas desde un memorial con los
restos de más de 250.000 víctimas macro
no admitió responsabilidad de francia en
la masacre pero sin una disculpa clara
sí
son aquellos quienes han atravesado la
noche los que pueden quizás perdonar y
darnos el regalo del perdón
tony hayward
sus palabras fueron algo más valioso que
una disculpa a nápoles they were fueron
la verdad
speaking the fruit hablar de la verdad
es arriesgado pero uno lo hace porque es
lo correcto
you know it the cost
it is right según un informe ordenado
por el propio macrón y publicado en
marzo por una comisión de historiadores
francia tiene una abrumadora
responsabilidad por no haber previsto la
masacre
es una herida aún abierta para los
supervivientes del genocidio que
esperaban esas palabras de perdón un
tipo visto es fascismo no podemos
olvidar tan fácilmente hay que ser
claros ellos participaron ellos ayudaron
se numera el momento de decir perdón
claramente sin irse de un lado a otro
con el ánimo de fortalecer estas frías
relaciones de los últimos 20 años macrón
anunció que designará a un embajador en
ruanda el primero desde 2015 macrón
también estuvo en sudáfrica donde junto
con su homólogo a decir ramaphosa se
comprometió a invertir en la producción
de más vacunas en áfrica pese a que el
continente no enfrenta la peor situación
en términos de contagios está
desproporcionalmente afectado por la
escasez de fármacos hasta ahora se han
administrado menos de dos dosis por cada
100 personas
uno de cada seis habitantes del planeta
viven en áfrica sin embargo hasta la
fecha en el continente africano sólo se
han administrado 28 millones de dosis de
la vacuna contra el cob y 19 de las
1.800 millones de dosis que ya se han
suministrado en todo el mundo esos menos
del 2 por ciento después de las
conversaciones con el presidente francés
en su visita el líder de sudáfrica culpó
a lo que denominó a partir de las
vacunas que es asombrosa desigualdad
manuel macrón por su parte subrayó que
si bien la excepción temporal de
patentes para las vacunas es importante
el reparto de dosis debe acelerarse
mientras no hayamos vacunado en todas
partes estamos expuestos al riesgo
porque significa que la epidemia puede
seguir propagándose entre los más pobres
que las variantes pueden llegar y luego
volver y por lo tanto nos interesa
quiero cumplir este objetivo en áfrica
que el 40 por ciento de la población
africana esté vacunada con aves de año y
el 60% a mediados de 2022 y de torneo de
clasificación por mil dos mil bandas que
aún poseen tanto administración
y el mundial de la salud dice que áfrica
necesita urgentemente al menos 20
millones de dosis de la vacuna
astrazéneca en las próximas seis semanas
para poder vacunar completamente a las
personas que ya han recibido las
primeras dosis una reciente prohibición
temporal de las exportaciones de vacunas
por parte de india ha provocado un
cuello de botella que ha afectado al
mecanismo kóvacs diseñado para
suministrar dosis a los países
empobrecidos los envíos de la vacuna del
joven 19 a los países africanos se han
ralentizado hasta convertirse en un
goteo este mes debido a la dependencia
de india como uno de los principales
fabricantes a nivel mundial cuando
tantos expecting el continente esperaba
66 millones de dosis a través de kóvacs
de febrero a mayo pero en su lugar sólo
ha recibido 18 2 millones 65 mil ya
algunos países africanos incluso han
estado reteniendo las dosis iniciales
preocupados por la posibilidad de no
poder administrar la segunda vacuna en
el intervalo recomendado la oms se insta
a los gobiernos a vacunar al mayor
número de personas posible incluso la
primera dosis aumentaría el nivel de
protección el tribunal constitucional de
malí declaró así migoya como el nuevo
presidente
el coronel que encabezó un golpe militar
en agosto contra ibrahim boubacar que
está se desempeñó como vicepresidente
hasta esta semana cuando ordenó la
detención del presidente y del primer
ministro interinos que ya fueron
liberados la comunidad económica de los
estados de áfrica occidental suspendió
la membresía de malí tras este nuevo
golpe militar
es el último capítulo en la evolución de
la crisis política de malí la comunidad
económica de los estados de áfrica
occidental suspendió al país del grupo
regional y pidió a sus gobernantes
militares interinos que nominen a un
nuevo líder civil de inmediato la
decisión llega después de que la nación
viviera un segundo golpe militar en
nueve meses
y aprovecho esta oportunidad para
reiterar en nombre de la comunidad
nuestro compromiso continuo con la
transición pacífica en mali
racing con el objetivo básico de
restaurar el gobierno democrático y
trabajar por la estabilidad del país y
de nuestra región la delegación del
grupo regional mantuvo conversaciones
con el líder interino de malí así migoya
en un comunicado emitido dijo que el
país debe cumplir con el compromiso de
celebrar elecciones presidenciales en
febrero próximo
guaita tomó el poder hace una semana
después de que soldados detuvieron al
presidente de transición y el primer
ministro pero luego los liberaron
asegurando que habían renunciado los
oficiales habían sido nombrados
tras un golpe de estado en agosto de
2020 también liderado por goitá y en el
que derrocaron al presidente electo
democráticamente ibrahim bubacar keita
esta no es la primera vez que la
comunidad económica suspende a mali la
medida también fue tomada en 2012 tras
un golpe militar
si bien el derrocamiento de keita en
2020 llevó al bloque a imponer sanciones
las medidas fueron levantadas en octubre
el república democrática de congo al
menos 400.000 personas necesitan apoyo o
protección tras haber sido evacuadas por
el riesgo de una nueva erupción del
volcán en gira' gongo naciones unidas
solicitó ayuda ya para los evacuados que
tienen dificultades para alimentarse e
hidratarse arena villacorta nos detalla
en la república democrática del congo la
fuerza de la naturaleza ha obligado a
400.000 personas a huir algunos lo hacen
a pie otros en carro o en moto otros por
bote y ahora luchan por sus vidas hasta
que otro la vio
con todas las dificultades que estamos
atravesando no sabemos si vamos a morir
hay mucho sufrimiento ni siquiera
tenemos comida dormimos en el suelo
aunque la iglesia nos ayuda a abrirnos
las puertas no pudieron encontrar comida
para darnos no tenemos agua ni siquiera
medicinas juana los niños han caminado
muchos kilómetros y dormimos muy mal por
lo que enfrentamos muchas dificultades
si bien la ma jin la crítica situación
de las miles de familias congoleñas que
han escapado preocupa distintas
organizaciones internacionales que
exigen ayuda humanitaria en la vida en
el congo aparentemente no es valorada
por el mundo tanto como la vida en
cualquier otro lugar
esto es en muchos sentidos parte de este
racismo institucional que hemos visto
por lo tanto europa américa del norte de
japón los países del golfo todos los que
tienen recursos son deben venir a
aliviar a la gente en el congo estos
niños necesitan esperanza necesitan
regresar a la escuela necesitan ayuda y
no la están recibiendo en este momento
a las evacuaciones se suman al menos 31
muertes cientos de desaparecidos
incluyendo a más de 170 niños y la
destrucción de 3000 viviendas que dejan
sin hogar a alrededor de 20.000 personas
según cifras establecidas por la oficina
para la coordinación de asuntos
humanitarios de las naciones unidas
entretanto otro de los peligros a los
que se enfrentan los evacuados es el de
contagiarse de cólera una enfermedad que
brota en el pueblo de saque uno de los
destinos de evacuación
y terminamos con música que nos llega
desde panamá donde cada 30 de mayo se
conmemora el día de la etnia negra
el objetivo de estas fechas reconocer y
resaltar los aportes de los afro
panameños a la historia del país este
año un artista luz para bolt aprovechó
la efeméride para lanzar su nuevo
sencillo titulado amo ser negra un
homenaje a la herencia africana en
panamá
afro panameñas gracias por estar con
nosotros quédense porque hay más mucho
más empresas 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
los rizos sabores y colores cuando me
voy
la negra tiene tumbao